Shrieve how's it going man well suddenly
how you been I'm doing well man her
husband like a year since we last talked
yeah from then to now like how house has
been this journey for your first year
three gym ball you know things didn't
work out you say I love the schools
other people their programs awesome
coaches players everybody's awesome but
I just feel like there wasn't really a
good fit for me so I I made I made other
moves and LSU was one of the first
schools that were true to me and I feel
like when I went there to visit it was
like oh you know people there didn't
really they didn't talk about my dad at
one time and now that kind of would what
stood out to me like even though he's a
statue outside the stadium they didn't
they didn't say we want you to be better
than your dad we need to be your dad
they're like when you'd be Shareef like
people here love you so the LSU family
is just they're just really supportive
so I feel like that was the best option
for me I remember you said that you
didn't play a lot your freshman year
high school yeah and you kind of had the
same reaction that this is kind of like
people who obviously said they see your
name they're like and then you don't get
the minutes we get you don't get to
really showcase which or you feel like
you weren't ready at that time so you're
really kind of prepare you for this time
around it's like I've kind of done this
where I've has to earn it again you know
I gotta keep earning it's always earning
it always earning so yeah I talked to my
dad he said it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen again
he said he's like remember freshman year
you played three minutes again there was
like two points everybody's talking bad
about you the next year came you got you
got better
you started becoming the man when you
went to crossroads then you really where
the man at crossroads he's like you got
to start over you're a freshman again
you're not gonna get as much playing
time as the older guys the coach is not
gonna treat you the same as he does
older guys you won't get away with the
same stuff I just want to learn the
college basketball game and just have
fun playing basketball just playing
basketball again this is a blessing even
though I couldn't really score when are
they getting a game when I wasn't a game
for those couple minutes I was just
happy to just be able to to put on the
jersey again and play again even if I'm
if I shot a shot and I missed it I was
that would be able to stop I know like
the passing code and how it kind of gave
you that extra like you know
appreciation for the game whatnot and
just like how you how much harder you
want to go like how I was going through
at home the day before and the day was
just really like it was unreal toast he
he was watching my little sister played
the day before
and then the next day me Aris me are my
little sister her team was going to play
GG's team me and Josh
miss the first game that my sister
played they're gonna play GG team at
like 11 or 12 me and Joshua in the car
just like your brother look at this he
shows me the phone and I see it says
Kobe Bryant's passed away and the
helicopter guys I'm like man get that am
i favoring that I see it and then I was
like kind of like I was driving I just
turned on my muse I'm like being like
I'm like somebody came late like you're
playing a joke like this so I'm like you
just hit me a hour ago eh what are you
talking about we go to my mom's house
waiting for my mom and them to come back
we're gonna head to a game my mom called
she's crying she's like they cancelled
all the games like Kobe and GG passed
away and then bike I don't know I kind
of just lost it I don't know I just kept
looking at my phone I kept looking at
the messages to see if he was gonna
answer I wasn't getting any answer and
then it kept going around and I got the
confirmation ID it was true and then I
kind of just walked outside and just sat
down on the ground and then me and Josh
just like we really just cried like I've
never had an emotional mum with him like
that but that's like been my best friend
for a long time so we just sat there we
cried for a long time because he Kobe's
meant a lot to him because he just
looked up with Toby and I personally
knew Kobe had a big impact on me and my
family that's always sticks to my mind
like my phone background it's just
literally that mess I look at every day
it's like just motivates me in a mine
like I went later that day I went to
Staples Center a lot of people were just
kind of like coming up to me in their
life
like you know that you were possibly the
last message that thought I mean you got
the last message that Kobe ever sent and
then some I don't know if that's true
but someone after someone told me I just
literally broke down started crying in
the middle of everybody there just was
so much love and like people like just
ran to people when they saw me Friday's
coming up like give me a hug it was so
unreal I still like to these days it's
just I don't really just want to believe
it was crazy
shifting gears like what was the light
for see you watching the state as a
whole like the kind of high school
basketball that was going to shoot it
was a big year and we thought about it
before to when he probably has some
advice for Romney as well I know you
guys know each other but like his first
freshman year was next for all NBA kids
like if for if your dad NBA player like
obviously people are gonna the first
thing you were gonna do for you are you
better than your dad or will you be
better than your dad so like we all kind
of know that we're always being compared
to our dad so we just kind of have to
try to separate ourselves and the thing
for Broni there's only gonna get worse
I've never seen people like like pack
out like a teenagers game like that like
I was like wow it's only gonna get worse
and brownies good once his body fully
developed secrets he gets like to his
maximum height and his Maxima he's gonna
be he's gonna be a problem so I mean I
know he knows what to do and he's doing
the right thing he's a good team player
he does he plays his role on that team
but with these seniors leaving not next
year he's gonna be pleasing to be a
killer if you could put together a
producer battle would you want to see
faceoff you can give me any combination
definitely definitely Southside Italy
South Side of course he's going first
and in the second one probably chase the
money his beats are fire or
pierre-pierre has really good beats
still I got a pyramid okay yeah here
I'll probably do Southside of here Alban
fire who do you kind of miss playing
with the most you can go back to what do
you miss playing with the message I miss
playing with Bowl know that time went by
too fast you know me a bowl like right
when I met bulls just say interesting
like it was an interesting clearly
that's best that's my that's like really
one of my best friends he's actually one
of the most unreal people I've ever seen
play basketball like 74 and kiss shoot
like that I think he could shoot better
than most like most guards I've seen my
balls really just he's literally a point
guard in a seven for body what is going
on with you and these karaoke and DJ
sessions that y'all got going on over
there
you know can you take us through these
parties that we're all missing out on
all right so everybody knows how like
animated my my daddy he's like a really
animated person he just always turned up
to the maximum
and he's like we don't be stuck in the
house we gotta find where's occupier so
so we will work out in the morning but
during night times it's all fun he said
I have all my DJ stuff here we have a
mic he's like y'all want to just throw a
little party for ourselves we were just
like all right yeah that's what I've
been doing that people loved that video
I didn't expect that video to blow up
like that but I mean it did how excited
are you with this next shot before and
what can you tell people about what they
should expect from Sheree I'm really
excited for this phrase next chapter you
know I kind of take to using this as
like a restart with Louisiana I feel
he's gonna be really good and you know
it's just it's a different type of
basketball you know West Coast
basketball is kind of like the finesse
basketball smooth but I feel like I'm
going to the South on my back like bang
with kids I'm like to do all this like
it's gonna be it's gonna be scratch so
it's a lot of learning it's gonna be
learning still you know it's my second
year basketball about to be my junior
year at school so yes it's gonna be a
lot a lot to learn that's what is a
learning experience
this is Sharif O'Neal would be our hoops